all right let's talk money with the
ever-changing economic outlook in the
world starting fresh
is the new year kind of a definitive for
many whether it's purchasing life
insurance buying stocks setting up or
contributing more to your 401k or
retirement plan
there's a lot of things people can do to
prepare for the years ahead
kirsten joyce is your financial advisor
right now she joins us from home with
some tips i care
[Laughter]
well not me but some other experts brian
we caught up with the ceo of brokers
international mark williams
he's got a great many suggestions for
people looking to make some positive
changes
first off he suggests that you make sure
you're contributing to your 401k
at least up to the company match because
that's free money
on payday he says treat your savings
account like a bill and
pay yourself first by putting money into
it
interest rates he mentions really low
the cheapest money people have seen
in years refinancing right now a huge
deal many refunds on a traditional
30-year loan are below 3 percent
williams also says you should consider
the following
there is a very good likelihood that our
we might have some tax increases
um simply because the old administration
again not want to talk politics but the
old administration reduced tax rates
the new administration is always talking
about increasing your tax rates
so the first thing you might want to sit
down with either your financial planner
or your hr department or do some math
what could that potentially mean to you
because you'll have less take-home
as far as life insurance williams says
the number one question to ask yourself
is
if you rely on someone else's income to
meet your needs
that person should have life insurance
and you should be the beneficiary
now there are two main types of life
insurance you've got term life basically
renting life insurance for a certain
number of years
and you have permanent life insurance
which of course lasts for a lifetime